géraud bonjour merci d'être avec nous ça
me fait plaisir jugez vous dites moi
c'est la première fois que votre bureau
fait l'évaluation des promesses des
partis politiques
ça s'est passé mais je veux pas tenter
ça parce qu'il reste encore une semaine
à la campagne électorale sage
oui je suis chez cei mais je peux dire
que jusqu'à maintenant ça s'est très
très bien passé on avait prévu avoir un
certain nombre de requêtes
on s'était préparé en conséquence et on
est et on a facilement atteint ce nombre
de requêtes là que je peux pas
malheureusement mentionné pour l'instant
parce que la campagne est encore en
cours mais on n'a pas eu de problèmes
majeurs avec les partis politiques on
n'a pas eu de problèmes majeurs non plus
dans les estimations et à ma
connaissance c'est tout le moins on
était capable de de rencontrer les
exigences des partis politiques est de
répondre à leurs besoins
on vous avait averti en début de
campagne on étend les pays qui gère déjà
ce genre de programme là je pense à
l'australie entre autres vous avez mis
au courant des risques ça représentait
parce qu'un au niveau du volume de
requêtes des précisions des dangers que
ce soit utilisé à des fins partisanes
avez vous l'impression vous les avez
évité tous les pièges là encore une fois
jusqu'à maintenant j'ai l'impression que
oui évidemment une utilisation des fins
partisanes c'est le but le but lui même
de l'exercice les partis politiques nous
demande estimé le coût de la promesse
électorale c'est pour qu'ils puissent
l'utiliser à des fins partisanes mais ya
pas eu de fuite ya pas eu d'un parti qui
est utilisé les promesses d'un autre
parti pour absolument pas jusqu'à
maintenant les parties se sont bien
comportés on peut utiliser nos services
à mauvais escient pour discréditer les
autres partis et lee la représentation
qu'ils ont fait de nos estimés a
toujours été grosso modo assez fidèle à
l'objectif qui avait été qui avait
établi dès le départ parmi les risques
qu'ils avaient sur la table au moment où
vous avez commencé l'exercice lequel
vous faisait le plus peur
ce qui était le plus gros risque le plus
gros risque selon moi c'était qu'est le
service l'opportunité qu'ils étaient
offertes aux parties ne soit pas prise
que les partis politiques et les
électeurs ne voient aucune valeur a cité
une
il ya eu une crainte là dessus et leur
donner des partis qui disent je sais pas
si on peut faire confiance à des fuites
exactement donc avec les doutes qui
avaient été exprimées par certains
acteurs politiques avant le début de la
campagne électorale ça soulevait la
possibilité que peu de partis politiques
ou même aucun ait recours à nos services
ce qui ne s'est pas produit si vous
regardez notre site web vous allez voir
que ya plusieurs parties qui ont eu
recours à nos services qui ont publié
plusieurs qui ont utilisé plusieurs de
nos estimés de coûts il ya main le parti
conservateur qui se vantent publiquement
avec raison d'avoir d'avoir demandé à
nos services d'estimer la totalité des
mesures de leur plateforme électeurs
donc si risque ne se sont pas
matérialisées à mon grand soulagement
y avait il y avait une possibilité que
vous aimez vous possédiez à l'évaluation
d'une promesse et que à la suite de
votre évaluation se soient pas publiés
est-ce que ça a été le cas ça a été le
cas à plusieurs reprises et je vois ça
comme une bonne chose dont vous avez
influencer un peu le discours politique
où vous avez et fleurance et certains
des choix qui ont été faits par les
parties
je dirais que l'information qu'on a
fourni aux partis politiques leur a
permis de mieux réfléchir à ce qu'il
voulait ou ne voulaient pas inclure dans
leur plateforme électorale
donc en ce sens cela on a eu une
influence je crois une influence
positive en leur fournissant des
renseignements qui était non partisan
professionnels sur le coût de ce qu'ils
proposent donc oui une influence mais
une influence très positive sur c'est
arrivé souvent
oui oui à plusieurs dizaines de reprises
je dirais on a aussi posé des questions
suite à la soumission d'une demande à
nos bureaux
et ces questions leur ont permis à
certains partis politiques de raffiner
leurs propositions ou de les modifier
juste par les questions qu'on pose est
salie forcé à penser à des détails
auxquels ils n'avaient pas songé donc
sans forcer les partis politiques à
mieux développer leur propre au style
aviez vous l'impression quand vous avez
commencé le travail que vous auriez que
vous joueriez ce rôle d'influenceurs
dans les programmes politiques vous avez
un peu joué de tous les partis
est-ce que c'était quelque chose que
vous aviez envisagé ça vous a surpris
ça m'a surpris parce que je pensais que
les partis politiques nous demanderaient
uniquement de faire d'estimation des
coûts et qu'il nous a livré avec des
politiques qui était à plus détaillée
que ça donc en nous fournissant des
soumissions des demandes pour lesquelles
des détails certains détails restaient à
déterminer
on a on a forcé où on a amené les partis
politiques à réfléchir plus que ce à
quoi je m'attendais non ça m'a surpris
est ce que les lecteurs canadiens et
bien servi par votre travail
ça va être ultime mans aux électeurs à
le décider
est ce que vous avez fait une différence
de prix d'après moi oui on a permis aux
électeurs aux partis politiques mais
d'abord et avant tout aux électeurs
d'avoir une bien meilleure idée des
coûts que de ce que les partis
politiques préparent ou strelli partis
politiques proposent aux électeurs donc
lille coup qu'ils ont été lus qui nous
ont été demandées ce qu'on a fourni aux
partis politiques
si les estimations de coûts qui sont non
partisane qui sont effectués par des
professionnels plutôt que par des
acteurs politiques qui ont beaucoup
d'autres choses à faire et qui peuvent
être tenté d'influencer ce qu'il
présente à la hausse ou à la baisse pour
diverses raisons
parlez moi du degré d'incertitude que
vous attachez à chacune des m chacune
des évaluations que vous faites
à quel point est ce que ça vient fausser
la lecture ou mettre un bémol à la moi
je suis un électeur je regarde la
promesse puis j'arrive à un fait
document sadique degré d'incertitude
élevé
est-ce que je devrais français sur six
est ce que c'est ce que ça veut dire que
la formation qui avait est exact mais
sans l'être
comment comment je dois évaluer sa le
degré d'incertitude qu'on attache aux
différentes estimations qu'on n'a pas
fourni ça vise à réduire dans l'esprit
des gens qui lisent ces estimations là
une idée de s que le chiffre lui-même et
précis où est ce qui est sujet à une
variation par exemple quand on estimé
des propositions visant
à taxer les géants du web ou
l'imposition des souliers fortune le
comportement de ces individus l'odyssée
corporation est difficile à prévoir donc
basé sur le stock actuel de personnes
très riches par exemple 20 millions et
plus on sait que on pourrait générer un
revenu x mais ce qu'on ne sait pas
précisément c'est dans quelle mesure ces
individus là aussi famille là vont
déplacer leur activité on a une bonne
idée basée sur ce qui s'est fait
ailleurs du comportement qu'on anticipe
de ces gens très riches là mais on le
sait pas précisément dans le contexte
canadien
je vous remercie beaucoup ça m'a fait
plaisir